Through the latter half of
the 19th century, Mark Twain was on a mission
to attack pretense with satire.
One of his most hilarious, if completely scandalous
and by many standards inappropriate, works
was a lecture he gave to The Stomach Club
in 1879 about masturbation titled, “Some
Thoughts on the Science of Onanism.”
During the 19th century, medical practice
had been increasingly incorporating scientific
thoughts and developments, including how disease
spread and the rise of anesthesia.
As such, simply calling something a “science”
at that time gave it a certain cachet, so
the irony of juxtaposing this honorific with
the topic of self-abuse (as masturbation used
to be called), would not have been lost on
the audience.
Nor would any part of Twain’s talk go unappreciated,
as The Stomach Club was a group of writers
and artists who loved to get together over
a delicious meal, and a few too many drinks,
and enjoy a bawdy tale.
That evening, Twain’s topic would not disappoint,
as Onanism was well known at the time as a
euphemism for masturbation
If you’re wondering, Onan was the guy from
the Old Testament who was killed for spilling
his “seed” on the ground instead of in
the lady- the oldest documented instance of
the withdrawal method of birth control being
used, which contrary to what many think is
actually nearly as effective at preventing
pregnancy as condoms according to a 2008 study,
Better Than Nothing or Savvy Risk-Reduction
Practice?
The Importance of Withdrawal, written by researchers
from Princeton, Central Connecticut State
University, the Guttmacher Institute, and
Ibis Reproductive Health.
Specifically, they note the withdrawal method,
while a poor way to prevent STDs in general,
when executed perfectly- which just means
withdrawing before ejaculation, aiming said
ejaculate away from the relevant lady bits,
and not having sex again until one has urinated
first to clear any remaining sperm out of
the urethra- is 96% effective at preventing
pregnancy if used as the primary means of
contraception over the course of a given year.
For comparison, using a condom, when done
perfectly, is 98% effective over that same
span and oral contraception has a “perfect
use” rate of about 99.7%.
Now this is when all three methods are done
“perfectly”, so what about in actual practice
with everyday people?
The pull and pray method is roughly 82% effective
while using a condom is roughly 83% effective,
give or take depending on which study you
want to go with.
The pill, in contrast, does offer a much better
“actual use” rate of around 96%.
In any event, back to Twain and his thoughts
on Onanism- getting off to a good start with
his speech, Twain began by referring to the
act as a “species of recreation . . . to
which I perceive you are much addicted.”
He goes on,
Homer, in the second book of the Iliad says
with fine enthusiasm, “Give me masturbation
or give me death.”
Caesar, in his Commentaries, says, “To the
lonely it is company; to the forsaken it is
a friend; to the aged and to the impotent
it is a benefactor.
They that are penniless are yet rich, in that
they still have this majestic diversion.”
In another place this experienced observer
has said, “There are times when I prefer
it to sodomy.”
Robinson Crusoe says, “I cannot describe
what I owe to this gentle art.”
Queen Elizabeth said, “It is the bulwark
of virginity.”
Cetewayo, the Zulu hero, remarked, “A jerk
in the hand is worth two in the bush.”
The immortal Franklin has said, “Masturbation
is the best policy.”
… Michelangelo said to Pope Julius II, “Self-negation
is noble, self-culture beneficent, self-possession
is manly, but to the truly great and inspiring
soul they are poor and tame compared with
self-abuse.”
…
Obviously a fan, Twain remained faithful to
his journalistic roots and gave equal time
to those who were not enamored with the ancient
art, noting
Brigham Young, an expert of incontestable
authority, said, “As compared with the other
thing, it is the difference between the lightning
bug and the lightning.”
Solomon said, “There is nothing to recommend
it but its cheapness.”
Galen said, “It is shameful to degrade to
such bestial uses that grand limb, that formidable
member, which we votaries of Science dub the
Major Maxillary–when they dub it at all–which
is seldom, It would be better to amputate
the os frontis than to put it to such use.”
Twain then turned to Darwin and the noble
monkey, stating,
Mr. Darwin was grieved to feel obliged to
give up his theory that the monkey was the
connecting link between man and the lower
animals.
I think he was too hasty.
The monkey is the only animal, except man,
that practices this science; hence, he is
our brother; there is a bond of sympathy and
relationship between us.
Give this ingenuous animal an audience of
the proper kind and he will straightway put
aside his other affairs and take a whet; and
you will see by his contortions and his ecstatic
expression that he takes an intelligent and
human interest in his performance.
Like a modern roast today, Twain couldn’t
resist sticking it to his audience a bit as
he opined that those who indulge in the recreation
too much can be easily detected by their “disposition
to eat, to drink, to smoke, to meet together
convivially, to laugh, to joke and tell indelicate
stories.”
Ultimately, however, Twain explained that
this science was the least efficacious of
all sexual acts since:
As an amusement, it is too fleeting; as an
occupation . . . too wearing; as a public
exhibition, there is no money in it.
It is unsuited to the drawing room, and in
the most cultured society it has long been
banished . . . It has at last, in our day
of progress and improvement, been degraded
to brotherhood with flatulence.
Among the best bred, these two arts are now
indulged in only private–though by consent
of the whole company, when only males are
present, it is still permissible, in good
society, to remove the embargo on the fundamental
sigh.
Finally, Twain concluded with these maxims:
If you must gamble your lives sexually, don’t
play a lone hand too much.
When you feel a revolutionary uprising in
your system, get your Vendome Column down
some other way – don’t jerk it down.
Circumcision in the United States did not
become popular because Christians were trying
to keep with the covenant between God and
Abraham, as is often thought today.
After 50 BC, circumcision remained, at least
popularly speaking, a largely Jewish affair
as it had been since at least 1800 BC.
However, there eventually arose a controversy
concerning the practice among Christians as
it was unclear whether the Gospel required
circumcision among converts, which would thus
restrict Christianity to Jews or Gentiles
willing to snip the tip.
Ultimately, it was decided that circumcision
was not a prerequisite to conversion, and
the Catholic Church maintained a degree of
hostility towards the practice which would
set the tone for circumcision among Catholics
and Protestants alike until the 19th century
(though of course Muslim groups would popularly
also eventually adopt the practice).
But as for the Western world, the popularity
of circumcision didn’t grow until the 19th
century as a way to try to discourage masturbation.
Clitoridectomies were also mildly popular
for a time as a treatment for masturbation
in women.
For more on this, see our video The History
of Circumcision.
Samuel Clemens grew up along the banks of
the Mississippi River, where he eventually
became a steamboat pilot in 1857.
It was from his experiences here that he came
up with the name “Mark Twain” sometime
around 1863.
This was river slang for 12 feet of water,
or two fathoms, with Mark twain literally
meaning “mark two” or the second mark
on the depth measurement line.